hey everyone welcome to the wh if live
stream it's great to have you all here
Mom I see you joined us today look I got
about an hour's worth of the best wh if
scenarios of the year to show you and
I'm eager to get started but I just want
to let you know what's in store now this
was a great year for wh if we covered
lots of new ground did some longer form
videos with me called wh if Originals
we're upping our game with visual
effects in our videos we launch our
patreon uh we introduced chase a new
virtual character who will appear in
some of our episodes look for him later
in the show but also watch for him in
his own spin-off show coming soon also
coming up at the show you'll find out
what evidence we might have about a type
2 civilization what Earth was like in
the age of giant dinosaurs and discover
things that you were lied to about
regarding space but first let me show
you an example of our elevated visual
effects that we're so proud of in our
first video today what if you spent 5
seconds on Venus everything anything in
the video except my voice is computer
generated let me know what you
think welcome to
hell yeah sorry I meant Venus welcome to
Venus some say it's Earth's twin but
this world is nothing like home and
you're about to experience this
scorching hot landscape
firsthand your mission is to spend 5
seconds on this hellish planet and trust
me these are going to be a very long 5
Seconds Venus is the second planet from
the sun and our nearest neighbor at its
closest approach Venus is a mere 40
million km away from us after Just 4
months in space you'd finally be able to
to witness this beautiful but deadly
Planet up
close 4 and2 billion years ago Venus and
Earth formed in the same corner of our
solar system this space rock is about
the same size as earth and its gravity
is similar too but unlike our home the
surface situation on Venus is
Extreme we know this because we've sent
probes to this scorching World some
probes orbited it some made a flyby and
some even landed on the surface of Venus
but those didn't last very long what
happened to them well that's what you're
about to find out time to make your way
down to the
surface ah don't these clouds look
beautiful well don't inhale them these
yellowish bands streaking across the sky
are clouds of sulfuric acid if you could
only get a whiff of them you'd smell the
week of rotten eggs but to do that you'd
need to remove your helmet and I
definitely do not recommend
that at a height of 50 km above the
surface visibility is poor you'd hardly
be able to see anything the incredibly
thick atmosphere would block views of
this planet and its tens of thousands of
volcano
knows the atmosphere is mostly made up
of carbon dioxide and because it's so
thick it traps heat on the planet's
surface keeping it nice and toasty just
how toasty are we
talking you're going to find out the
hard
way as you descend another 15 km the
haze would begin to clear the world
below would finally reveal itself a rust
colored surface covered in mountains and
volcanoes looks like this volcano is
still
active you'd fly around a little to
collect some samples and take in the
view yep the atmosphere is mostly carbon
dioxide with traces of nitrogen that
checks out okay well let's see if you
can land here this looks like the spot
Mission Control am I clear for
landing mission
control uh looks like there's no signal
initiating The Landing sequence without
clearance fingers
crossed Landing your spacecraft would
kick up clouds of dust that would take
several minutes to settle down in the
soupy
atmosphere as it clears you'd look up
into the sky but you wouldn't find the
familiar yellow circle of the sun on
Venus it always looks like Dawn no
matter what time of day it is that's
because the venusian atmosphere only
lets about 10% of the sunlight that hits
it reach the
surface but wait what were we saying
earlier about the space probe that
landed on
Venus oh yeah vanera
13 this Soviet probe made its fatal
Landing back in
1981 it Survived The Descent and lasted
for a whopping 127 minutes that's longer
than any other spacecraft that had made
it to the surface but then vanera 13
gave way to the violent uninviting
environment of this hell it was likely
crushed under extreme pressure or it
melted but it's too late to turn around
now you've lived through the 1hour long
landing and you're so close all you need
to do to complete complete your mission
is to spend 5 Seconds out
there yeah out there in the most extreme
environment you've ever been
to you made it wa the atmosphere is so
strange you can hardly lift your arms
even though Venus has about the same
gravity as Earth you'd be feeling the
sheer weight of its immensely dense air
it would feel like you were walking
through water very hot water and you'd
be glad you were wearing so much
protective gear a quick look at your
thermometer would tell you that it's a
sweltering
475° C out here that's hot enough to
melt lead your pressurized suit would be
working hard to keep you safe with
without it you'd be crushed under all
that pressure before you could even
complete your mission this isn't so bad
after all hey if a spacecraft could last
over 2 hours some 40 years ago well you
and your shiny new gear can survive
longer right Venus is right here for you
to discover just take a few more
steps suddenly something distracts you
from the first ever firsthand human
analysis of Venus's surface conditions
your protective suit
breaks the DraStic pressure shift would
immediately make you feel like you were
deep
underwater with an atmospheric pressure
90 times that of Earth Venus would be
crushing you from all
directions at the same time you'd be
struggling to breathe in an atmosphere
without any Oxygen any atmosphere you
did manage AG to inhale would scald the
inside of your mouth and the top of your
throat unless you could scramble very
quickly back to the safety of your
spacecraft you'd be dead within
seconds hey it could be worse high above
you sulfuric acid clouds would be
raining acid but in this unbearably hot
environment the toxic rain wouldn't
reach the surface it would evaporate
long before that so at least you
wouldn't have to worry about acid
dissolving your skin and
bones that would be kind of
gruesome you know in hindsight maybe we
shouldn't have sent you down to explore
this hellish
surface of all the planets in the
universe Earth is clearly the best for
life
right wrong Earth may be great but
scientists have discovered a few worlds
that could be even better for
Life behold koi
[Music]
very far away the top spot is held by
one 3,000 light years away from our
solar
system koi
5751 would appear to satisfy the most
basic requirement for supporting life it
exists in the Goldilocks zone of its
star so conditions wouldn't be too hot
or too cold for a key life supporting
ingredient to exist on its surface
liquid water but it would also check off
many boxes to be considered super
habitable the planetary system it
belongs to could be 52 billion years old
which would make it around 1 billion
years older than our own solar system
and the planet would almost fit the size
requirement when looking for
superhabitable worlds scientists keep
their eyes peeled for planets that have
a mass up to one in half times of our
planet and they should be about 10%
larger too this size difference would
help the planet retain heat and if its
average temperature was about 5° C
higher than Earth's well this planet
could have even richer
biodiversity now being almost double the
size of Earth koi 571
5.01 might overshoot this condition in a
bit besides studies indicate that this
planet is actually colder than Earth but
there's still hope with the right
atmospheric composition a strong
greenhouse effect could raise
temperatures to the desired level and as
far as super habitable worlds go well
we're just getting
started approximately 2700 light years
away is Kepler 69c
this super Earth could be around 7
billion years old this puts it perfectly
in the estimated 5 to 8 billion year old
age range for superhabitable planets
this range is based on the 3 and2
billion years it took for complex life
to appear on Earth so the best chance
for finding life could be on a planet a
little older than us only this exoplanet
could be a little too big to be super
habitable
it has a mass almost four times that of
Earth a rocky planet this big could have
a single colossal continent that would
have huge deserts in its Center but the
coastline Washed by Kepler's ocean could
be your perfect spot to move
to our next superar shares a similar
name Kepler
1126b except it would be located every
so slightly closer to home yeah this
planet is about
273 light years away and it belongs to a
system that is 7 and a half billion
years old it also orbits a yellow dwarf
star much like our own only Kepler 1126b
is 2 and a half times closer to its star
than Earth is to the Sun but that's no
big deal because the star Kepler 1126b
orbits is cooler than ours so the
habitable zone would exist in a Range
much closer in proximity to
it if you aren't feeling this nearness
to a scorching hot star there's another
Super Earth on our list and it's at a
reasonable distance from
home speculo 2C is located only 106
Lighty years away not that its proximity
gives it any kind of Advantage it would
still take you well over 200,000 years
to travel to this super Earth and that's
if you moved at the speed of NASA's
Parker solar probe the fastest probe
ever
launched speculo 2C does look promising
though it's about 40% larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours now
despite the fact that it also exists in
the habitable zone its red dwarf star is
still very small it's only about 15% the
size of our sun so this planet orbits
around its star at a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculo 2C is tidally locked to its
star this super Earth takes 8 and 1/2
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star that would leave one side of the
planet in constant daylight and the
other in Endless Night this means that
life could be possible in The Terminator
Zone the thin strip of land between the
two sides we just need to get a better
look to find out for
sure okay my choice there would be the
speculo planet now if you know anything
about speculo you'll know that the
planet was named after these cinnamon
Ginger nutmeg cookies from Belgium I
call them windmill cookies they're
delicious now how much time did you
spend in History Class well the average
high school history course has you in
the classroom for
about20 hours each year for some people
that's an eternity not me I loved it but
what if I told you I could give you the
history of the Earth in 10
minutes yeah 4 and a half billion years
of history in the time it takes to boil
a cup of tea watch
this in the past few billion years Earth
has been pummeled by asteroids crashed
into other planets and frozen over
several times not to mention being ruled
by all kinds of crazy life
forms sometimes it's it's a wonder that
our blue home world has survived at all
but if we want to take a whirlwind tour
of our planet's history we'll have to
start way back at the very
beginning some 4 and A2 billion years
ago our solar system began to emerge out
of a dense cloud of interstellar gas and
dust This Cloud collapsed into a
swirling d disc of matter that got
hotter and hotter and hotter until
hydrogen fused into
helium and just like that our son was
born and baby Earth was on its way too
after the birth of our star all the
matter on the farthest ends of the
spinning disc began to Clump together
these clumps would be the seedlings for
the planets and moons in our solar
system as they accumulated more matter
they grew bigger and more spherical the
clumps in the cooler regions of the
solar system were mostly made of ice
liquids and gases closer to the Sun all
the rocky material formed the inner
planets like Mars and Earth this young
Earth was incredibly active volcanically
speaking it spewed out gases like
hydrogen sulfide methane and carbon
dioxide these gases made up the very
first atmosphere on our planet early
Earth was constantly bombarded by large
asteroids and comets and soon Earth
experienced an even more violent
Collision Thea a planet the size of Mars
slammed right into our Young World this
epic Collision threw chunks of matter
all around Earth's orbit and then
gravity bound them together into what we
know now as the
[Music]
moon on this hot early Earth there were
no oceans all water existed as gas but
3.8 billion years ago our planet cooled
enough for water to condensate and
become liquid the very first primitive
ocean covered this young Earth and
turned it into a water world H2O is an
essential ingredient for creating living
things so with all that water life
appeared on Earth about 3.7 billion
years ago these earliest forms of life
were microscopic organisms but it was
nearly a billion years after that that
some of these organisms changed the
course of the
[Music]
world Earth didn't stay as a water world
very long
soon the very first continents emerged
from the ancient ocean scientists call
them
cratons as more and more land Rose from
the ocean the very first supercontinent
appeared on the planet valbar wasn't
exactly a super continent it was pretty
small scientists think it was smaller
than the continent of
[Music]
Australia around 2.4 B million years ago
cyanobacteria evolved to become our
planet's first
photosynthesizers finally we had some
oxygen producers to make Earth's
atmosphere much more hospitable and the
rest is history
folks just kidding we've still got a
long way to
go with all this new oxygen Earth's
atmosphere had much lower levels of
carbon dioxide and that made the planet
icy cold much of our Young World froze
over as Earth saw its first Ice
Age now as Earth's atmosphere was
changing the continents were moving too
they broke up and reassembled into the
next supercontinent
rodinia rodinia was a real
supercontinent it may have been the
largest supercontinent to ever cover the
planet and life well life finally became
more
complex but then something
happened rodinia broke apart and a new
supercontinent assembled this one was
called
pinosa then between about 540 and
485 million years ago there was an
explosion of new life this time was
called the Cambrian explosion and the
animals that evolved during this period
had hard body parts like shells or
spines the most famous of all were the
alien looking
[Music]
trilobites around 440 million years ago
the climate suddenly shifted and the
temperature of the ocean changed
dramatically Earth saw its first mass
extinction event this was the oriv
vision silurian Extinction and a
majority of the life that had been
spreading around the planet vanished
many of these life forms laid the
foundation for the ecosystems that we
have on Earth today somewhere between
420 to 350 million years ago the first
trees arose from Earth's soil and the
first animals made their way to land
too
250 million years ago the planet was
covered by Our Last vast supercontinent
Pangia sadly it was also during this
period that Earth witnessed the greatest
mass extinction event in our history the
great
dying huge amounts of greenhouse gases
and accelerated global warming wiped out
about 90% of all species on Earth but
the this mass extinction helped pave the
way for the next wave of animals to
evolve 240 to 230 million years ago the
first dinosaurs appeared for the next
150 million years they'd rule the land
if you were there you'd have witnessed
the gigantic sorod
Argentinosaurus the largest land animal
ever or you might have been chased by
one of the earth's greatest Apex
Predators the
T-Rex and you'd also witness Pangia
breaking up and forming the continents
we know
today okay you may already know where
this is
headed 66 million years ago an asteroid
slammed into our planet right where
Mexico sits now and it coughed up so
much debris into the atmosphere that it
blocked out the sun this led to
devastating climate changes that caused
the dinosaurs to die
out in the next wave of emerging animals
mammals became more
[Music]
common around 6 million years ago the
earliest known humans started walking
this world this species was called
sahelanthropus though they still likely
walked on all fours 4 million years ago
early humans began to walk up right and
about 1 million years later they develop
the first known tools which they used to
break things some 800,000 years ago
things sparked these early humans
discovered how to control fire and could
now cook food and provide themselves
with heat their brains continued to
evolve now more rapidly than ever these
humans learned to interact with each
other and the surrounding World in whole
new ways
then between 40,000 to 15,000 years ago
all other human species besides Homo
sapiens went
extinct 10,000 years ago Earth saw its
earliest Farmers these previously
nomadic humans stopped wandering the
planet and finally put down their Roots
jumping way forward to about 250 years
ago the Industrial Revolution took place
we went through major technological
socioeconomic and cultural
Transformations rural-based Farm
societies became more industrialized
Urban ones our human population
continued to grow by 1804 we reached 1
billion by 1927 we'd hit 2 billion and
since the 1960s the global population
has risen faster and faster to where it
is now at over 8 billion people and now
there's a new threat to human existence
and many other forms of life here on
Earth climate change temperatures and
sea levels are rising worldwide and
biodiversity is
declining we could be on the verge of
another mass extinction event if things
don't
change our sun looks nothing like this
it looks more like
this if you've always thought our sun
was a bright yellow ball of fire you
were wrong for starters it's not yellow
it's
green sort
of scientists determine the temperature
of a star by the color spectrum it emits
each color has its own wavelength and
astronomers measure those wavelengths to
tell how hot a star is cooler stars
appear red the hottest of the stars look
blue our sun emits most of its energy at
a wavelength that's close to
Green but because it also emits other
wavelengths all these colors mix
together and your eyes see this vibrant
mixture as white that is if you look at
the Sun from the International Space
Station from here on Earth the Sun looks
yellow because our atmosphere is really
good at scattering blue light
and with all that blue wavelength gone
all the other colors combine into yellow
if our star was actually yellow it would
be about 800° C cooler our Solar
System's habitable zone would shrink and
Earth would become a frozen lifeless
Rock but that's not the only thing you
were wrong
about the Sun is hot but it's not on
fire burning is a chemical reaction of
oxygen with
fuel like most stars out there our sun
is a ball of gas mostly made up of
hydrogen and helium it doesn't have much
oxygen in it instead it works more like
a gigantic nuclear reactor constantly
fusing hydrogen atoms to create helium
inside its core this process releases
enormous amounts of energy and that's
why the the sun is so scorching hot
speaking of setting things on fire let
me tell you about explosions in space
yeah these aren't real a spaceship can't
go down in a violent blast because
there's no air out there in space No Air
means no oxygen and no oxygen well as
you already know means no fire sorry
Star Wars
fans it may seem that there are too many
stars in the night sky for you to count
but actually you can although scientists
at Harvard have already done it for you
according to the Yale bright star
catalog there are
9,110 stars that you can see from Earth
with the naked eye try to count them all
for
yourself movies make it look like you
need to be an extremely skilled pilot to
navigate the asteroid belt but that's
not true the asteroid belt isn't some
thick obstacle course of of death it
does have trillions of space rocks that
range in size from space dust to a
quarter the size of the Moon about
100,000 of these asteroids are over 1 km
wide but they're very spread
out the asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter is
225 million km
across that's 1 and 1 half times the
distance between Earth and the Sun and
this spreads the space rocks millions of
kilometers apart it's almost impossible
for a spacecraft to collide with one if
you were thrown out of the airlock into
the vastness of space you wouldn't turn
into a popsicle right away that's
because to freeze there has to be a heat
transfer from space to your body but
heat or cold doesn't travel very fast in
the vacuum of space your body would
freeze but it would take hours to happen
and by then you'd be long dead from
something else and no you wouldn't
explode in space either you would
inflate though that's because nitrogen
in your bloodstream would gather into
bubbles and puff you up to double your
size but that's not what's going to kill
you it's the lack of oxygen after 15
seconds in space your brain wouldn't get
enough oxygen through your blood and
you'd lose
Consciousness after 2 minutes in space
your other organs would start to shut
down one by
one game
over space seems incredibly cold but
it's not in reality space doesn't have a
temperature at all temperature is
defined by the speed at which particles
move and the amount of energy they have
in the true vacuum of space there are no
particles to move
around that's why the vacuum is
temperatures of course outer space isn't
a perfect vacuum it still has particles
and radiation to produce heat some areas
of space are actually really hot like
the space around
stars but the further away you get from
Stars the more spread out the particles
are making those areas of space pretty
chilly some dense gas clouds can get as
cold as minus
263°
C Mercury is the closest planet to the
Sun but surprisingly it's not the
hottest it is Extreme though during the
day the surface temperature reaches
430° and at night it drops to - 180
but the most hellish planet in the solar
system is Venus you see Mercury doesn't
have an atmosphere to retain all that
heat from the Sun the venusian
atmosphere on the other hand is very
thick and it creates a greenhouse effect
it's like global warming on
steroids and it makes Venus a hot hell
with a surface temperature of about
475°
our entire solar system isn't just
sitting in one spot in our galaxy it's
hurdling through space at 220 km/ second
that's seven times faster than the speed
that Earth revolves around the Sun our
solar system takes 230 million years to
make one orbit around the Milky Way yeah
the last time we were in the same
location we are now now Earth had one
supercontinent and the dinosaurs were
just starting to roam around planets do
not orbit around the sun all the things
in our solar system are in balance and
even though the sun is the most massive
object in our planetary neighborhood
other planets are participating in this
gravitational tug of
war in instead of orbiting the Sun
planets and moons orbit around a central
point
between them and our star this point is
called the Berry Center for Earth this
Berry Center is so close to the sun's
core that there's not much of a
difference but for Jupiter this point is
about 55,000 km away from the center of
the Sun so the gas giant and the sun are
orbiting each
other Earth appears round from space but
it's actually an irregular L shaped
ellipsoid it bulges at the equator
thanks to the centrifugal force caused
by our planet's spin as a result Earth
is about 43 km wider at the equator than
it is at the poles this makes gravity at
the Bulge slightly weaker making it
easier to launch spaceships from the
equatorial regions than from the
poles in space no one can hear you
scream
Ah that's only true to a point sound
needs a medium to travel through and in
space molecules are very far apart so
the sound Fades away before it can get
very far all the cosmic catastrophes
supernovas and colliding black holes go
quiet before you can hear them but some
places in space have a lot of particles
for sound to travel through like the hot
gas cloud around the black ho hole at
the center of the percus Galaxy cluster
it has so much gas that you can actually
hear the black hole this is what it
sounds
like you know that point about
astronauts growing 2 Ines taller in
space has me intrigued it'd be pretty
nice for me to go into space and gain a
few inches in height you know what else
would be nice if you bought a copy of
the what if 100
100 of our most popular hypothetical
scenarios explained with science Bound
in beautiful hard cover with the forward
written by friend of the show
theoretical physicist Dr Michio Kaku you
can pick one up in our merch store at
shop.und.com lots of other stuff there
too like shirts hats beanies coffee mugs
go on you know you want something check
it out now you've heard of cryosleep
right well it's the use of super low
temperature temperatures to put the body
into a state of suspended animation now
the hope is that humans will one day be
able to use it for space travel giving
us the ability to go to sleep for years
at a time until our spaceships could
reach a distant planet like Kepler
[Music]
22b
635 light years from where you are
sitting way out there in outer space
lies a planet the first planet to be
discovered within the habitable zone of
a sunlike
star its name is Kepler
22b when a planet is located within a
star's habitable zone it means there is
a chance that liquid water exists on its
surface and where there's water there's
also the possibility of life
human
life how long would it take to get to
Kepler
22b what would the weather be like over
there and why would you need to get
jacked before arriving on this new
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if you live on Kepler
22b Kepler 22b is what scientists call
an EXO Planet it's a planet outside our
solar system spotting an exoplanet like
Kepler 22b is often not easy the bright
glare of the Stars they orbit tends to
keep them hidden from our
telescopes what did scientists come up
with to get around
in looking at the stars themselves to
see if they can find anything unusual
about them they spotted Kepler 22b using
What's called the the transit method
they watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time that
was because Kepler 22b was blocking the
Stars light with this scientists were
able to learn both the size of 22b and
how it orbits and it looks like this
distant Space Rock could become our next
home okay but what do we really know
about Kepler
22b its mass is 36 times that of Earth
with a radius of 2 and 1/2 times larger
than ours one year on Kepler 22b is 290
days it's also located 15% closer to its
star than we are to the sun if Earth
scooched over that close to our
star you'd be fried Kepler 22b on the
other hand is lucky to have a sun that
is remarkably similar to ours but also
smaller and cooler this close proximity
to its star allows the planet to receive
about the same amount of sunlight as we
get over here the temperature on Kepler
22b could be about 15 to 22° C similar
to Earth's Spring weather and quite
habitable if you ask
me but our galaxy can be a cruel place
and not everything is good
news some models suggest Kepler 22b is
rotating on its side kind of like our
very own
Uranus this may sound insignificant but
it adds potentially deadly
complications this would mean that its
North and South poles are shrouded in
either Darkness or sunlight for half a
year
and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler 22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to
freezing which wouldn't be great for
human
life I know what a bummer but don't
despair yet
because
known about Kepler
22b for starters we still don't really
know what gravity is like there it could
be twice as strong as our our planets if
that was the case a 10 kg sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kg and your
body would also factor into the mix is
your current weight 75 Kg well good luck
suddenly dealing with 150 kg of you and
just for safety settlers such as
yourself would need to bulk up really
bulk up only through intense strength
training would you to increase your
chances of being able to walk on Kepler
22b and once you got jacked on Earth
you'd have to figure out ways to
preserve that muscle through all
635 years of light speed
travel but humans aren't the only life
form that would be affected by a
stronger gravity plants brought from
Earth for oxygen and nutrition might not
survive on Kepler 22b when you try
growing them there
and if you brought any animals with you
they'd need to step up the evolution
process higher gravity could lead to
creatures developing additional legs to
move around it could also determine the
location and size of internal
organs but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler 22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gous similar to Neptune or
it could be entirely covered with water
if you and the other first settlers woke
up from your cryo sleep and found
yourself on a gas planet yeah that would
be a downer you wouldn't have a solid
surface to even land your ship not to
mention a place to set up camp in that
case you and your crew would need to
figure out how to build a cloud city
orbiting the planet if you you landed on
an ocean planet a submarine town would
be in
order discovering Kepler 22b is a rocky
planet would be hitting the jackpot then
right well not so fast Venus is also
made of rock and yet its dense
atmosphere consisting of greenhouse
gases makes it uninhabitable with
scorching temperatures far too hot for
liquid water if this was also the
situation with kep 22b our only chance
at thriving on this exoplanet would be
to employ robots that could build
underground shelters the place where
maybe just maybe the temperature might
be cool enough for you to
Bear it just goes to show you that a
prime location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own own Earth Remains the perfect
Habitat for Humanity millions of years
ago Earth looked very different all the
continents were fused into one teaming
with life both beautiful and
terrifying when you think of prehistoric
times you might picture a T-Rex
rampaging through the jungle with its
razor sharp teeth but even before the
dinosaurs there were other giant
creatures ruling the Earth yeah welcome
to the peran period this epic started
300 million years ago back then our
planet had one supercontinent Pangia
surrounded by a world ocean called
panthalassa the peran period began at
the end of an ice age when temperatures
were much cooler than today then during
early per Ian days Earth warmed to a
lush environment with a diversity of
plants and a rapid evolution of insect
and animal life only as you probably
know everything is Ever Changing on our
Blue Marble over the next 50 million
years Earth kept growing hotter and
drier eventually the most deadly event
in the history of our planet wiped out
nearly everything that ever lived here
scientists called this event the great
dying and it was the most catastrophic
mass extinction event the Earth has ever
seen and the Earth has seen five of them
but before we get to all this Doom and
Gloom let me take you on an Epic Journey
back in time here in the peran period
some of the most incredible species that
roamed our young Planet are about to
emerge
if you could time travel nearly 300
million years into the past you'd land
smack dab in the middle of the superc
continent
Pangia Earth's smaller continents would
have just finished colliding with each
other to form this enormous land mass
taking up onethird of the planet's
surface there was likely less oxygen in
the air than there is now but you still
might be able to breathe
oh and bring a jacket because it would
likely be chilly with some areas
averaging no more than a Brisk 4°
celsus but don't worry things will soon
start heating up by the end of the early
peran the Ice Age was on its way out and
Pangia was becoming a lush
world plants and animals started to
thrive this was a volcanic world World
violent eruptions changed the climate
shaped the landscape and paved the way
for
evolution when giant swamp forests began
drying out plant life had to adapt and
so 290 million years ago Earth saw the
very first seed bearing plants called
gymnosperms these plants carried seeds
on their cones and they spread across
the super continent like
wildfire the ancient Evergreen Forest of
the early peran was hiding something
familiar just like today you could find
cicas and beetles piercing and sucking
on the plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches only these weren't the
Cockroaches you know today these
prehistoric Vermin were gigantic the
size of
birds but despite their size cockroaches
never ruled prehistoric land and that's
good news am I right
no something much more fascinating was
roaming Pangia the now extinct ancestor
of primitive mammals
dimetrodon this animal was as
fascinating as it was
terrifying encountering a dimetrodon
would be quite a sight to behold this
ancient lizard grew to 5 m long and
weighed 225
kg it had a large sail running down on
its spine scientists think this saale
helped the reptile regulate its body
temperature soaking up warmth during the
daytime and dissipating excess heat
during the cooler nights it would walk
toward you like a crocodile and act like
a total Menace dimetrodon was an apex
predator of its time watch out for a mix
of sharp and flat teeth that would slice
you open and grind you
up
in the middle perian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet
therapsids they had strong jaws with
sharp teeth and a somewhat upright
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies
therapsid reptiles varied from the 5 m
long likely omnivorous dudosa surus to
the five times smaller meing
lops you could meet plenty more more
therapsids if you stuck around for
another 20 million
years during the middle perian period
Earth kept getting hotter the average
global temperature on Pangia grew to
about 25° C and volcanoes were spitting
greenhouse gases out into the atmosphere
due to the changing climate sea levels
were shifting but marine life found ways
to thrive if you were to take a dip in
the prehistoric super ocean you'd be
swimming alongside ancient sharks and
bony primitive fish many more complex
marine species came and went as the
environment kept
changing in the late peran period you
could have a friendly encounter with
another reptile
lystrosaurus these looked like a cross
between a lizard and a pig but unlike
all the scary prehistoric monsters out
there lystrosaurus was a herbivore it
was just 1 M long and had powerful front
legs for burrowing soon another cute
mamal likee lizard evolved the
codon the codon looked like a giant
rodent it was about 1 M long had
whiskers and fed on small animals and
insects now during this time something
bad was brewing in the air a large
amount of volcanic activity was
displacing oxygen from the atmosphere
scientists think there was as little as
10% oxygen in the air compare that to
21% today you'd have a hard time
breathing in that environment and the
temperature kept rising and Rising with
an average temperature of about 28° C
this Lush prehistoric world was turning
into an
oven
all good things must come to an end and
sadly this period came to a particularly
brutal one about 252 million years ago
about 90% of all plant and animal life
was wiped out this tragic moment is
called the Great dying and it was
Earth's most devastating mass extinction
event scientists still debate what
caused this catastrophic Extinction most
theories suggest it was the result of
explosive volcanic activity as huge
volcanic eruptions swept the continent
massive amounts of Ash were Unleashed
into the atmosphere so much Ash that it
blocked out most if not all of the
incoming sunlight and with no sunlight
global temperatures dropped suddenly
plants couldn't perform their
photosynthetic processes and died off
and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon
followed things got worse before they
got better because of all the carbon
dioxide emitted during the volcanic
eruptions global temperatures rose again
and not just to where they were but
higher much higher and this caused the
super ocean to lose most of its oxygen
and unable to breathe a majority of the
perian sea animals perished eventually
over 95% of marine species and More than
70% of land animals became extinct so
that's what life was like before the
dinosaurs and then about 250 million
years ago after the great dying well the
dinos started to evolve on Earth they
ruled the planet and stuck around for
about 145 million years until a massive
asteroid hit the Earth and caused the
next mass extinction event sad yeah but
uh I'm not too broken up by the fact
that I'm not dodging Velociraptors on
the way to work every day now let's take
a look at how it all went down and what
the Earth was like immediately after the
dinos died out 66 million years ago an
asteroid as big as Mount Everest was
headed on a deadly Collision Course with
Earth the impact was so devastating that
it wiped out the most gigantic deadliest
reptiles to ever roam our planet but the
dinosaurs didn't just die from one big
boom no they faced a slow agonizing
end how did this Extinction event cause
the largest tsunami Earth has ever
seen and what exactly happened after
after the big reptiles were
gone Hold On Tight we're taking you on
the most epic and deadly trip of your
life this dinosaur ending asteroid is
terrifying Not only was it about 10 km
in diameter but it also traveled
incredibly fast between 10 and 30 km/
second at this point it was a blazing
Fireball
as it hurdled down to earth the air in
front of it was compressing and heating
up to unimaginably hot
temperatures just before the impact the
asteroid could have been as hot as the
surface of the
Sun once it entered our atmosphere it
only took this massive Space Rock a few
seconds to reach Earth's
surface and alter the course of life
forever as the asteroid slammed into
Earth off the coast of where Mexico is
now it sent huge amounts of debris up
into the air the shocking blast wave
killed everything in its way and from
here it was only getting
worse this powerful blast ejected bits
of the Earth's surface into the
atmosphere and minutes later scorching
hot pieces of glass and rock rained back
down some of the debris reacted with the
atmosphere causing acid rain that would
last for years the land was burning the
fires caused by this devastating impact
spread across the continent like literal
Wildfire killing more and more Life
along the way and then just when you
thought the apocalyptic scenario
couldn't get any more
intense well it
did the impact of the asteroid hitting
Earth was so powerful that it sent shock
waves through the
planet and all that energy had to go
somewhere cue the meat
tsunami a wall of water over 10 m High
raced across the
ocean this wasn't your regular tsunami
it was a staggering 30,000 times more
powerful than anything you see
today as this monstrous wave spread
across the North Atlantic and South
Pacific coastlines didn't stand a chance
the wave hit with such force that it
destroyed and reshaped the continent if
you were there to witness this
apocalyptic destruction well you
wouldn't survive any of it but some
dinosaurs did yeah the ones further away
from Ground Zero weren't immediately
obliterated by the impact they weren't
incinerated by the resulting infernos
and they managed to avoid being Swept
Away by the mega
tsunami but still their fate was
sealed as the dust began to settle it
was the start of a nuclear winter even
though it wasn't nuclear weapons that
caused it the effect was the same the
massive amount of debris in the air
blocked the sunlight for months maybe
even years Earth suddenly became a cold
dark place and the Dinos weren't ready
for it as temperatures plummeted and
fires released enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases the climate changed
dramatically plants weren't able to
perform photosynthesis and most of them
started to die out this disrupted the
food chain and starved many of the
animals that survived the impact and
remember the acid rain it lasted for
several years causing more Devastation
to the ecosystem
the oceans became too acidic for marine
life most ocean species didn't have the
time to adapt to such a drastic
change these prolonged harsh conditions
together with the initial blast pushed
about
75% of Earth's life to
Extinction the good news is is that this
included the horrifying
T-Rex yeah as much as I feel bad for
this guy I'm happy he's not running
around
today when the last of the dinosaurs
breathed their last breath Earth became
an empty devastated Place cold and
acidic so when did things get back to
normal yeah well here's the thing they
didn't not dinosaur era normal
anyway Earth didn't rebuild after that
it reinv vented
itself 1,000 years later the planet was
recovering from the post-apocalyptic
winter it was still cold and food was
still scarce but life was ready to make
a comeback in this new Wild World a few
furry Little Critters were sprinting
around among the first plants to
reappear after the impact were ferns
they really hit it off well after the
disaster 100,000 years later Earth began
to get a little more lively creatures
about the size of raccoons were
repopulating the continents and the
oceans were once again teeming with life
fast forward about 10 million years and
Earth had finally restored its
biodiversity only it wasn't the same
Earth as it used to be now it was the
age of
mammals yeah after the dinosaurs checked
out mammals were on fire yeah not
literally of course mammals together
with birds and flowering plants were
rocking the planet yeah Earth never got
back to its old self after the last
dinosaur died it took our planet
millions of years to bounce back in a
new way but don't get me wrong this
world was still pretty terrifying it had
beasts like
parum roaming the land and mega adon's
reigning Terror in the
oceans yeah it's really for the best
that most of these creatures aren't
around these
days
Titan the most majestic of Saturn's many
moons and the most promising for life
too it's got a beautiful view and liquid
Lakes on its surface the only problem is
those Lakes aren't filled with water
they're filled with liquid
methane your mission is to take a
5-second dip in one of
them of course you'd have to land on
Titan first so buckle up for the most
epic adventure of your
lifetime Titan is far even at its
closest to Earth this icy moon is still
1.2 billion kilm away from us you'd be
looking at roughly 7 years of travel
alone in a spaceship you'd need lots of
provisions and a super Advanced life
support system you know it would be good
if you made it to Titan and didn't
freeze or suffocate somewhere in the
middle of the solar
system yeah that's not going to happen
to you just sit back and enjoy the
ride
seeing Saturn up close is
amazing definitely the most spectacular
of all the ringed planets in the solar
system but hey enough sightseeing it's
time to make your way to your
destination Titan is unique in many ways
for one it's larger than our moon it's
even bigger than Mercury the smallest
planet in our Cosmic neighborhood it's
the only Moon that has a thick
atmosphere it's also the only one that's
covered in liquid lakes rivers and seas
and sometimes it rains here
too descending on Titan would take you
about 2 and 1 half hours and you
couldn't just land anywhere like I say
Titan is covered in Lakes so unless you
wanted to dip your entire spacecraft in
liquid methane
you better choose your Landing site
carefully let's try this
[Music]
again okay now that you've properly
landed on Titan let's go explore this
icy
world this moon of Saturn might look a
lot like Venus but it's not as hellishly
hot Titan is one of the most hospitable
places in the solar system
yeah its gravity is only 14% of Earth's
but its thicker atmosphere makes it
possible for you to walk there even
without a space suit but I wouldn't
recommend that you'd need the space suit
to keep you warm Titan is very far away
from the Sun so it doesn't receive as
much warmth as we do here on Earth you'd
be taking a Brisk stroll at a chilling
minus 180°
C well you wouldn't exactly be strolling
more like bouncing around yeah thanks to
Titan's weaker gravity you'd feel a lot
lighter and could jump higher and move
with less
effort now Titan's atmosphere is mostly
nitrogen very similar to Earth's but you
still couldn't breathe on this Moon
because well that's where the similarity
ends while 95% of the air here is
nitrogen the remain remaining 5% is
methane you'd need an oxygen tank to
survive even 5 seconds on this
world yeah it's not just the lakes that
have methane in them there's plenty of
methane in Titan's clouds and sometimes
it even rains
methane but this rain isn't anything
like you've seen on Earth it would be
more like rain and slow motion thanks to
Titan's lower gravity and thick
atmosphere on Earth raindrops fall at
about 9 m/s but on Titan their speed is
only about 1.6 m/ second that's six
times slower it would be pretty cool to
walk in the rain here but hey you didn't
come here for a walk in the rain you
came to take a dip in Titan
Lakes I wouldn't do that if I were you
oh excuse me who's
here all right let's do this what's up
everybody I'm Chase I'm from the year
3050 and for the last well things are a
bit wobbly where I come from I've been
traveling through space and time a lot
thing is I die a lot like a
lot it's kind of like my special
power it all started when I touched this
shiny alien Cube now I can jump Between
Worlds Dimensions time and when I die I
always come back I'm still trying to
figure that one out I I think it has
something to do with Einstein
I don't
know it's pretty cool I jumped on the
rings of distant planets been the guest
of honor at an alien feast and not in a
good
way and there was that one time I
accidentally started an Interstellar War
cute but now I'm here on Titan to stop
you from doing um whatever it is you're
doing because you only live once unless
you're
me so your mission is to take a a swim
in one of these methane
pools let me break it down for
you first off this ain't no spa day it's
like diving into a freezer Titan's got
this super chili vat going on you know
what I mean at these temperatures
water's harder than concrete but methane
and ethane they're like yeah it's cold
brv but like we can still chill in
liquid form and so they gather up in
these cool little
pools okay I knew that too sorry no
interrupting I'm still just getting to
the good part now let's say you're
wearing that fancy space suit good news
you won't freeze instantly into an
astronaut popsicle bad news that suit's
going to
float if for some wild reason you
decided to take the plunge without the
suit well that's it my friend lights out
you see the intense cold would freeze
you down to your bone you couldn't move
a muscle and then the lack of oxygen
would
get
jump but 5 seconds with the space Su on
we'll definitely survive probably let's
test
it
[Music]
okay ah seems like someone space Tu
can't withstand the Cod
someone needs an
upgrade it's so refreshing out here I
think I'll just stay another 5 Seconds
just
to really enjoy
it oh oh hot hot hot hot hot hot uh
Chase ah don't worry these Sparks are
supposed to happen oh it's like a
stabbing burning
feeling it appears that the cold
temperature cracked his suit and methane
reacted with the oxygen tank inside
it he should have read about this in the
mission brief well just leave him here I
guess anyway the mission is a success
the only thing left is to figure out how
to get home so that's chase our new what
if Explorer and as you saw he dies in
space that's kind of why we named his
new upcoming show Chase dies space
genius right now you may have noticed
that on this show by the end of every
what if scenario everybody dies #
shop.und.com
well since Chase is 100% virtual he dies
but he always comes back to life for a
new episode that's why we couldn't send
me too dangerous you'll see Chase pop up
in a few more wh if episodes and then
we'll be giving him his own YouTube
channel it's all quite exciting but not
quite as exciting as our Patriot
join the what if Explorers Club on
patreon it's where we give you all the
top secret behind the scenes extended
director's Cuts mind-blowing art epic
merch discounts and Our Endless Love and
gratitude oh and we'll even let you
pitch ideas for upcoming episodes
support us on patreon to get exclusive
content and help me send Chase to his
death over and over and over again okay
this next one was one of my favorites of
the year I learned a lot about the
Carboniferous period it's also called
the coal age but it's also famous for
something else giant
insects over 300 million years ago
before the age of giant dinosaurs Earth
was covered with giant
insects imagine a world where dragon
flies are the size of crows and
millipedes are as long as cars
welcome to the Carboniferous
period why were insects so enormous
during this
time what did oxygen have to do with it
and why did these insects go
extinct this is what if and here's what
the Earth looked like in the age of
giant
insects the Carboniferous period was one
of the most transformational periods in
the history of of Earth the planet's
land masses were beginning to form the
supercontinent of Pangia extensive
swamps and warm humid forests dominated
the
landscape and giant insects weren't the
only huge creatures roaming the planet
there was also a vast array of marine
life like early forms of sharks and a
giant amphibian that would reach up to 6
ft
long now enough talking let's travel
back in time 300 million years ago and
dive in the Carboniferous
age now the first thing you'd probably
notice would be the giant insect likee
creatures one of the most iconic was the
Mega nura this insect resembled a
modern-day
dragonfly except with a major twist it
had a wingspan of up to 75
cm yeah scary than that though it was
carnivorous hunting down other insects
and small
amphibians hopefully it doesn't come for
you so that thing is in the sky but on
land you'll have the arthr plura this
millipede like creature could grow up to
2 and 1/2 M long luckily it wouldn't go
after you it preferred munching on
decomposing vegetation hey before we
talk more about these giant in sex
there's another giant issue we need to
worry about and that's our planet's
ecosystems and how important it is to
help them stick around till the end of
this video to check out an inspiring
project from the folks over at Planet
wild another creepy looking insect was
the pulmano
Scorpius this was a giant scorpion that
mostly roamed the sampier areas of Earth
they could grow 70 cm
long there were also giant cockroaches
that that grew to 10
cm and mayflies with 45 cm
wingspans so it's safe to say that you'd
have a lot to watch out for when you're
wandering around in this period but the
question is how did these insects get so
big anyway well you may have noticed as
you've been hanging around in the
Carboniferous age you feel a lot more
energetic and alert maybe you've had an
easier time running around this has has
to do with the oxygen levels in your
current world research has estimated
that the atmospheric oxygen levels were
as high as 35% during this period
compare that to the 21% we breathe today
oxygen was one of the key factors in the
gigantism found in insects at the time
but why would this make them so
giant insects breathe differently from
other creatures insects don't have a
circulatory system to transport oxygen
instead it gets delivered directly to
their tissues through a network of tiny
tubes called the trania and the more
oxygen in the atmosphere the bigger
these insects are but there might be
more reasons why the insects grew to
this size another theory suggests that
the insects were forced to grow so large
due to oxygen
toxicity yeah as amazing as oxygen is
you can't can have too much of a good
thing too much oxygen in your body can
create what's known as free radicals
these are unstable molecules that can
damage your cells and even damage your
DNA in the case of our insects they were
forced to grow this big otherwise they'd
suffer oxygen toxicity growing larger
would slow down the rate of oxygen
absorption making it harder to suffer
from too much oxygen
and the same could happen to you the
longer you hang out in this period the
higher oxygen levels will cause you to
experience nausea respiratory issues and
even some effects on your nervous system
now insects were arguably the stars of
this age but they weren't the only
things to experience massive change
during the Carboniferous period this
time was known as the coal age that's
because of the extensive coal beds that
formed after ancient forests
decade these coal beds are one of our
main sources of energy we're still using
them
today and a lot of the fruits and
veggies you find in the grocery store
may be descendants of plants from over
300 million years ago the Carboniferous
period saw the evolution of the first
seed bearing plants creating more
diverse ecosystems than we'd ever seen
before wait what's that over there kind
of looks like a
dinosaur oh hey little guy turns out
this wasn't a dino just one of the first
reptiles to ever appear but if you stick
around a couple of million more years
we'll enter the meso era which was known
as the age of
dinosaurs speaking of change the
atmosphere was another part of Earth
that evolved during this period Earth
had a lush greenhouse-like climate when
you first arrived warm and humid
temperatures to support the swampy
forests we've been mucking about but as
the period progressed over millions of
years the climate transitioned to what's
known as an ice house Earth State the
temperature would get significantly
lower and ice sheets would begin to form
mainly in the southern
hemisphere but why did this happened
well as we've been exploring this crazy
period earth's land masses have been
slowly coming together to form a
supercontinent known as
Pangia and when land masses this big
start to move it can seriously affect
ocean currents wind patterns and Global
Climate now the rain forests have
collapsed which has led to a decline in
the fauna and vegetation that were
previously
booming and with the rainforests in
Decline well that means oxygen levels
are being reduced before you know it it
our massive insects start dying and
going
extinct without the higher levels of
oxygen available to support their size
well these giant insects can't
survive the lower oxygen levels and a
drier climate have created a habitat
better suited for smaller
insects also happening at this point
early reptiles are starting to take over
making the landscape way more difficult
for the
[Music]
insects researchers have detected
strange radio signals coming from deep
space these mysterious radio waves might
just be bursts of cosmic energy from a
distant neutron star or it could be that
scientists have discovered a highly
Advanced civilization 90 light years
away from
Earth so what kind of civilization would
have the ability to send strong signals
like this well scientists classify
civilizations on something called the
kardashev scale it's a scale that
measures a civilization's technological
ability to harness energy while it's a
hypothetical scale that could eventually
have five or more levels most scientists
only refer to the first few but don't be
underwhelmed we're the only civilization
we know of and technically we're still
stuck on type
zero at this stage we've managed to
harness some but not all of our planet's
potential energy we consume about 18
trillion watts of power every year and
if we wanted to bump ourselves up to a
type one civilization we need to consume
over 500 times that every second to to
do this we'd need to harness store and
utilize all of the energy available to
us that includes all raw materials and
every bit of sunlight that reaches Earth
we'd also have to tame volcanoes
earthquakes and other Natural
Forces at the rate at which we're
developing now it's possible that we
could be a type 1 civilization within
the next 200 years
but whatever civilization scientists may
have discovered in the far reaches of
space could already be a type 2
civilization or
higher once our civilization has all of
the energy available on our home planet
under control and we graduate to a type
one on the cev
scale then we need to take the next step
time to crank up our energy consumption
to 10 billion times what it was before
to do this we'd need to harness not just
all the solar energy that reaches Earth
we'd need all of the energy our star
generates
period if there is a type 2 civilization
out there they're probably using an
incredible system to do this a Dyson
Sphere they'd build this Mega structure
around their star to collect all the
energy it radiates out in every
direction diretion they could even
assemble other Dyson spheres around the
first Dyson Sphere to guarantee that
little to no energy
escapes but there's nothing simple about
this technology and that's why only
Advanced civilizations could construct
something like it for one a Dyson Sphere
must be larger than the star
itself and if these Mega structures are
bigger than Stars well they should be
easy to spot right well this could be
tricky once a civilization is finished
building the Dyson Sphere the mega
structure blocks nearly all of the
visible light from its star a
civilization this Advanced could make
its own solar system invisible lucky for
us visible light isn't the only way to
detect a star even with a Dyson Sphere
blocking its light a star would still
radiate heat and we could detect the
Star by the infrared light it gives
off but that wouldn't be the only way we
might discover a civilization this
Advanced remember that strange radio
signal it originated about 90 light
years away from Earth coming from the
Star HD1
16459 was this powerful radio signal
created by an alien race and
intentionally pointed toward Earth a
civilization able to pull this off would
need to be far more advanced than our
own this type 2 civilization would be
able to utilize the raw materials on
every planet in its star system and
maybe even Beyond they may have built
Fusion reactors that orbit their Planet
fueled with gas from other worlds with
hydrogen-rich
atmospheres and they might be mining
precious metals from rocky planets just
like Earth
they could terraform other planets into
livable worlds for their populations and
they wouldn't live in fear of
civilization ending natural disasters
like asteroid impacts ice ages or global
warming because they'd have Technical
Solutions for these too this alien
civilization would be at the stage on
the kardashev scale where they'd be able
to master Interstellar travel but if
that's true there should be no reason
for them not to pop by for a visit
right well not so fast with all the
advanced technology they might have at
their disposal these aliens could be
waiting for us to catch up that way when
our civilizations meet we would do so as
equal
Partners who knows they could be so
Advanced that they're no longer a fully
biological race they could be more like
cyborgs with a mix of robotic and
organic
material this would make them capable of
incredible things that humans could only
dream of but they wouldn't stop there an
advanced world like this would want to
go farther up the kardashev scale and as
they became a type three civilization
they'd rely on something other than the
power of their own star system they
would harness the power of several stars
in their
Galaxy with this much power a civil
ization would have no problem meeting
its ever growing energy needs they'd
just hook up another star when they
needed more
power if we ever Advanced to this level
we'd have 100 billion stars available to
harness in the Milky Way galaxy alone a
civilization like this would no doubt be
the rulers of their Galaxy and they'd
have the power to move entire star
systems merging them to harvest the
energy they need more efficiently
so if one of these civilizations existed
well you could detect them by observing
the sudden disappearance of many stars
in a far away Galaxy this could be a
sign that Dyson spheres have been
constructed around not just one but
several
Stars a Type 3 civilization could
already be out there yeah after all
scientists have announced that they
found two galaxies with a highly unusual
amount of infrared light
this is something we usually observe in
galaxies where new stars are being born
but some unusual and sudden spikes in
infrared light could mean that we found
the first signs that civilizations many
times more advanced than us exist maybe
they're about to make contact or maybe
they already
have if this this is how you picture
walking on
Uranus you're
wrong let's start this
again are you ready to take a trip to
the outer regions of the solar
system to explore the weirdest planet in
our Cosmic
neighborhood to venture down into a
place that's never been studied up close
by any
spacecraft buckle up for an ice
violent and stinky Adventure because
your mission is to spend 5 seconds on
Uranus and come
back if you
can traveling to Uranus would be a long
strange Journey first you'd have to
spend 10 long years in a spaceship
speeding toward the outskirts of the
solar system if you're lucky you might
even pass Jupiter and Saturn on the way
just make sure you pack enough food and
fuel well there are some things you
should know about this world Uranus
isn't a rocky planet like Earth it's an
ice giant like Neptune and it's the only
planet in the solar system that spins on
its side it spins fast too one day on
Uranus is just 17 Earth hours
of course you wouldn't last that long on
it not a
chance once you arrived at your
destination you still have some work to
do to get close to this giant blue
planet you might have to dodge Uranian
Rings yeah Uranus has rings 13 of them
they aren't big and Majestic like the
gorgeous rings of Saturn the outer rings
are bright and easy to spot but the
inner rings are narrow dark you'd have
to navigate this part of the trip with
the utmost
care as you made your way through the
dusty rings of Uranus you'd see its
glorious blue atmosphere up close for
the first time in human
history take a moment to enjoy the ah
Uranus what an odd balls Planet you know
I flew by it a month ago that was fun
you want know why nobody and I mean
nobody has ever tried to land anything
thing on the surface of this bootyful
planet because Uranus has no surface
it's just a swirling ball of toxic gas
compressed around a small icy core oh
and wait till I tell you why those gases
on Uranus are
toxic
yeah gross yeah okay thanks for your
input Chase it's true Uranus might have
a calming blue color but it's cold and
toxic not the kind of blue planet you
want to
visit that's okay I think you should sit
this one out here I go
[Music]
woohoo it's brisk here oh Rico what's
the temperature - 224° c oh that's cold
that explains why I can't feel my
fingers or my toes or the rest of my
body okay well at least those 5 seconds
are done okay Rico it's time to go home
let's bounce impossible if my
calculations are correct you will reach
the icy core in 54.4 minutes so what
that wasn't the plan it what's point4 of
a minute use seconds you dumb bot I
suggest you take this opportunity to
study the planet up close and report
back well I suggest you take this
opportunity and stuff it up your
charging port I don't have a charging
port no one car cares
Rico no one cares honestly this sucks
Uranus smells
like yeah the reason Uranus smells so
bad is that the clouds in its upper
atmosphere are partially made up of
hydrogen sulfide not only does this make
the planet stink but it's also pretty
toxic whatever you do do not inhale it
if you did it' make you faint and die
instantly
what would have been real nice to know
this before I jumped yeah well after
falling through the stinky clouds at the
top atmosphere you'd find yourself in
the mix of 82% hydrogen 15% helium and a
bit of
methane methane gas is what gives Uranus
that bluish green Haze because it
absorbs light at the red end of the
spectrum huh these uh these clouds are
getting a little weird kind of
floaty yeah the atmosphere on Uranus is
very dense after passing through its top
layer you'd stop falling and start
swimming in it instead as you were
paddling deeper you'd start getting
pelted by Frozen gas
crystals but at least the temperature
would be rising I don't know about that
I don't feel warm at all Rico give me
the stats the temperature around you has
indeed gone up to
-28° C my calculations show you can
expect
-3° C in the lower atmosphere cool
great
ow what is that that well that's Diamond
rain yeah on Uranus it rains
diamonds that's because the Uranian
atmosphere is rich in methane a single
carbon compound under extreme pressure
the methane molecules break apart and
crystallize into diamonds but the worst
part is the wind you'd be dealing with
winds gusting at speeds of up to 900
kmph that's 3 and 1/2 times stronger
than a category 5 hurricane here on
Earth Rico it's getting tight in here oh
I can hardly breathe and when I do
breathe it smells like ass of course the
pressure is 100 times greater than the
atmospheric pressure of Earth's sea
level you are approaching the
mantle the good news is you wouldn't
splatter on anything because there's not
much in the way of solids on Uranus the
Uranian mantle is made of water ammonia
and methane ice it would be Pitch Black
in here and thanks to the extreme
gravity you wouldn't be able to move a
muscle and it would still be incredibly
cold what you should be worried about is
the immense pressure that would be
rapidly increasing the closer you got to
the planet center it would squish you
before you ever got to the
core being crushed by Uranus I always
thought it would be way
nicer well in this extreme pressure
environment your carbon-based body could
turn into diamonds and drop down into
the core what a spectacular way to
finish this one-way trip to the center
of
Uranus Chase oh all
right okay that's it for today's show
thanks for bearing with us and beholding
the Beautiful bounding and buoyant best
of what if for 2023 hope you enjoyed it
hope you learned a lot we'll be back
soon with another what
if hey everyone welcome to the wh if
live stream it's great to have you all
here Mom I see you joined us today look
I got about an hour's worth of the best
wh if scenarios of the year to show you
and I'm eager to get started but I just
want to let you know what's in store now
this was a great year for what if we
covered lots of new ground did some
longer form videos with me called what
if Originals we're upping our game with
visual effects in our videos we launched
our patreon uh we introduced chase a new
virtual